if you're a gamer you probably still
have some of your games for various
Nintendo consoles stashed away in your
closet along with your Lisa Frank
Trapper Keeper or your old Transformers
toys party with these classics could
earn some cold hard cash
for the right titles of course these
price estimates are based on video game
price charting sites and recent eBay
options and focus only on games that
have been used if you kept your games
sealed in the original boxes you were
probably a really boring kid but
obviously seal games are worth a whole
lot more so what's worth the most today
bonks adventure originally released for
the doom turbografx-16 console Fox
Adventures developers ported their
quirky 2d platformer to the NES in 1994
in the game you control bunk a hard
headed cave boy who battles prehistoric
enemies by literally head-butting them
to death if you've got a copy of bonks
adventure for the NES hiding in your
collection it's worth quite a few bones
about $400 for the cartridge Bubble
Bobble part 2 the second installment of
the Bubble Bobble series sees the return
of bub and Bob a pair of humans turned
dragons who must make their way through
increasingly difficult stages by barfing
up bubbles to trap their enemies the
gameplay is similar to other Bubble
Bobble games although the NES version
also includes bonus stages in case you
ever wanted to play Bubble dragon
volleyball which probably isn't a
euphemism a Bubble Bobble part two
cartridges worth approximately $300
panic restaurant it's a literal food
fight when chef cookie has to battle his
way through six levels filled with food
beasts with nothing but a frying pan the
stylish mustache the game features some
of the most seriously deranged boxart of
all time but even if you've only got a
loose copy of panic restaurant it's
worth around 540 bucks or one night with
Gordon Ramsay Aero fighters games where
you pilot fighter planes are a dime a
dozen but Aero fighters stands out by
being one of the rarest titles ever
released on the Super NES those gameplay
is predictable on the critics of the day
called this version mediocre the once
worthless kart became desirable simply
because there aren't too many of them
out there this one comes in at five
hundred and fifty nine dollars the
cartridge alone but you probably won't
want to waste too much time playing it
Haagen a the final conflict a
side-scrolling action platformer for the
super nintendo featuring a cyborg ninja
on a revenge quest if you're not already
completely sold on Haugen a final
conflict it's time to put your inner
child on a milk carton because it's
missing
with a futuristic setting challenging
stages and advanced controls Haggadah
has become a cult classic currently you
can get around four hundred and
seventy-five dollars for a loose
cartridge metal warriors stomp down puny
humans smash their walls and blast giant
robots while piloting a mech assault
suit in the Super Nintendo game Metal
Warriors it's set in a dystopian future
with remaining metal warriors defend the
earth from the evil dark Axis forces if
you've got a copy it can fetch you about
$200 or about one one-millionth of the
cost to buy a robot death machine of
your very own worms armageddon you
control a team of angry worms in this
turn-based military strategy game for
the Nintendo 64 as you advance through
your handle it any Me's you can upgrade
and gain new weapons including the Holy
Hand Grenade from the film Monty Python
of the Holy Grail currently the game is
worth approximately two hundred dollars
or twenty-five pounds of nightcrawlers
bomberman 64 the second attack in this
sequel to Bomberman 64 you controlled
Bomberman on an action adventure to save
the world from possessed Knights demons
and even a goddess well the game doesn't
have graphics on par with some of the
other n64 titles of its era Bomberman 64
the second attack does give Bomberman a
backstory if you really want a complex
history of a guy who's mostly fun
because he blows stuff up he can sell
this game for about $150 cubivore
survival of the fittest cubivore is an
action-adventure title where you must
guide your floppy cubic avatar through
the world and make it stronger by
devouring other cube avars or strangely
enough mating with them in the game's
convenient love tunnel you absorb their
power or make more powerful babies and
you remorselessly consume and impregnate
your fellow creatures until you can take
on the big boss killer cubivore cubivore
can net you about a hundred and thirty
dollars for the gamecube disc alone or
about the price of a visit to of real
love tunnel shantae the first in the
Shantae series of platformers you guide
Shantae a half Genie on her fight
against a dastardly female pirate with a
terrible name risky boots the series has
been wildly popular since its first
release in 2002 with a fourth
installment of the series set to be
released in late 2016 if you're lucky
enough to have wished for a copy for the
Game Boy Color handheld console you
could sell the cartridge today for 290
dollars
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which valuable
games you found in your closet